Trascrizione: Sara Falchi
Revisore: Laura Leotta
Sono Federica Guadagnolo, ho 23 anni
ed ho riflettuto a lungo
su cosa portare su questo palco.
A quest’età pensi a tante cose,
hai la testa che ribolle,
hai tanto da dire e può essere difficile
veicolare il pensiero e il messaggio.
Ho deciso allora di partire
dalla mia storia per parlare,
riflettere su cosa significhi
essere giovani al Sud Italia oggi.
E quindi eccomi.
Sono nata a Milano.
Dopo pochi anni mi sono trasferita a
Salerno e al compimento della maggiore età
18,
sono andata a Gorizia per studiare.
E nel momento della laurea, nel 2021,
ho di nuovo fatto le valigie,
salutato la mia famiglia
e mi sono diretta in Medio Oriente.
A Beirut per la precisione,
dove ho vissuto per circa otto mesi.
Seguendo questo filo
di spostamenti e biglietti aerei
da settembre vivo a Londra
per completare i miei studi.
Ma di cosa parla questa storia?
Questa storia parla di giovani, di fuga,
di speranze, ma soprattutto
della frenetica e incessante mobilità
verso il Nord che accompagna
una pesante mobilità nel Sud
e tra il Sud stesso.
Questa storia, per quanto caotica sia,
non rispecchia nient’altro
che un ricorrente pattern
di circa 1.138.000 persone
che nell’ultimo decennio si è spostato
dal Mezzogiorno al Centro-Nord.
Sono infatti i dati a parlare.
Ma il punto è che mentre i dati
sono chiari, la narrativa predominante
nei media e nel dibattito comune in merito
alla migrazione giovanile interna
in Italia tende al mero sensazionalismo.
Così facendo, è molto facile entrare
in una dinamica per cui ci si distacca
dalla riflessione sulle ragioni
che ci fanno apparire questa migrazione
come inevitabile, ma non ci permette
neanche di capire cosa questo processo
produca a livello immateriale,
nella costruzione dell’identità
sia collettiva sia dei luoghi
che inevitabilmente vengono abbandonati.
Ed è qui, in realtà,
che è racchiuso il messaggio.
Il messaggio è riflettere.
Riflettere per capire
che tutto ciò è un problema collettivo,
strutturale e che è verso la collettività
che bisogna spostare l’attenzione
per poi tornare, creare e non perdersi.
Io lo so che a parole sembra facile,
ma la verità è che le ragioni strutturali
che portano a migrare dai luoghi
in cui nasciamo e proveniamo hanno creato
un confine immateriale
che divide il paese.
Questo non è nient’altro che un confine
socio-economico, una linea di demarcazione
definita dal livello di produttività
del nostro paese.
Infatti, i confini che immaginiamo
il più delle volte come rigidi e statuali,
utili alla chiara demarcazione
tra chi è dentro e chi è fuori,
possono e anzi sono riprodotti
in maniera invisibile e permanente,
ma non per questo meno reale,
all’interno dello stesso territorio.
Come può, d’altronde, essere meno reale
e tangibile questo confine
se l’efficienza dei trasporti,
la qualità dell’istruzione,
e la maggioranza dei posti di lavoro,
per citarne solo alcuni,
sono maggiormente
diretti e localizzati
al di fuori dell’area geografica
in cui una giovane come me è cresciuta.
Ma questo perché questi sono proprio gli
strumenti attraverso i quali il confine
viene tracciato e mantenuto, con la chiara
conseguenza di vederci crescere
molto spesso con l'idea
di dover andar via.
In realtà, è interessante spendere giusto
due parole sui trasporti
e in special
modo quelli ferroviari in Italia.
I trasporti definiscono i percorsi e le
connessioni tra le città e i paesi, ma
soprattutto giocano sull'importanza del
tempo e su quanto il tempo acquisti
valore in base alla destinazione
produttiva o meno che ha.
In Italia, le reti ferroviarie veloci sono
sviluppate principalmente al Nord
e verso il Nord.
Nel Sud, alcune città, o forse potremmo
dire anche la maggioranza, rimangono
ancora irraggiungibili o sono collegate
solo alle città più grandi vicine, che
a loro volta sono collegate in modo
efficiente solo verso il settentrione.
Siamo immobili nelle nostre città, ma
siamo estremamente mobili verso dove si
trova la produttività e il risultato, nel
mio caso, è sentirmi rimossa dal ritmo
funzionale del tempo e insicura rispetto
alle mie prospettive future.
Ogni identità esiste per via esclusiva.
Siamo qualcosa perché non
siamo qualcos'altro.
E quando ciò si intreccia con le dinamiche
del confine e della migrazione,
si crea un processo di ridefinizione
della propria identità collettiva
legata alla memoria del territorio
da cui si proviene.
Si crea quel “qualcos’altro”
che proviene dall’interno
ovvero, noi giovani di qui.
Nasciamo, cresciamo e così stiamo
con l’idea che ad un certo punto
della nostra storia
dovremo migrare.
Il luogo da cui proveniamo è arretrato,
non è produttivo e in sostanza
rappresenta proprio tutte quelle qualità
di quel “qualcosa” in cui non vorremmo
rispecchiarci e per questo nemmeno vivere.
Non a caso Sarah Ahmed,
che è un’attivista, scrittrice
e teorica femminista, parla di un processo
specifico che chiama orientamento.
Ovvero essere orientati significa capire
qual è e dov'è il nostro posto nel mondo
e come poterlo raggiungere tramite
atti materiali e immateriali.
In questo caso, nel nostro caso, crescere
con l'idea di dover lasciare il nostro
territorio d'origine ha fatto sì che
abbiamo iniziato a orientare il nostro
futuro, i nostri sogni e le nostre
speranze in un luogo lontano
da quello da dove proveniamo.
E abbiamo iniziato a trovare casa
in quelle pratiche consuetudinarie
rappresentate dagli spostamenti.
Io, per esempio, inizio a sentire l’odore
di casa quando sono sul treno,
quando sono in aeroporto,
quando raggiungo il gate.
Tutte queste azioni, che sono diventate
un mero contenitore in cui ho racchiuso
tutta la mia esperienza della mobilità,
dello spazio, del tempo, della migrazione.
Questa continua tensione tra il dentro
e il fuori è una lotta, è una lotta
per non sentirci tagliati fuori
da un sistema produttivo,
ma spesso ci fa dimenticare cosa succede
ai luoghi e alle comunità che lasciamo.
Lo spopolamento del Sud Italia
e soprattutto delle sue zone interne
è in crescita, rispecchiando così
l’emorragia di giovani del Paese.
Ma è anche la ragione per cui io sono
grata di essere su questo palco oggi,
spazio di cultura.
A poterne parlare da un’altra prospettiva.
Lo spazio, infatti
non è materiale, non è geografico.
Ma come Lefebvre, famoso sociologo
e filosofo, teorizza, lo spazio
non è nient’altro che un prodotto sociale
o anche una complessa costruzione sociale
basata sui valori ed i loro significati,
che condiziona il modo in cui viviamo e
percepiamo lo spazio fisico
che ci circonda.
In parole povere, questo significa che
c’è un intrinseco legame tra noi
e i luoghi in cui viviamo,
creato proprio dal significato
che noi stessi gli attribuiamo.
E quindi, se non si può dare una soluzione
alla crisi dei giovani in questo paese
e in special modo nel Sud Italia,
in soli dieci, quindici minuti,
si può invece dare valore alla potenza
sovversiva che gli spazi di cultura hanno,
al portato rivoluzionario che questi spazi
creano in un vuoto, in un buco nero
in cui non ci sentiamo ascoltati,
capiti e valorizzati.
Sarebbe bello pensare invece a noi giovani
come agenti del cambiamento
del nostro futuro.
Noi giovani che andiamo,
noi giovani che restiamo,
noi giovani che ritorniamo  e resistiamo
come giovani agenti del cambiamento
del futuro nostro e della collettività.
Non possiamo cambiare a parole
l'irrefrenabile mobilità che si intreccia
con l’ingombrante immobilità, ma possiamo
riunirci, discutere, riflettere
e creare spazi, cercando proprio
di distruggere il confine.
Rubando le parole ad un rivoluzionario
d'eccezione come Antonio Gramsci.
Mi piacerebbe proprio concludere così.
“Istruitevi, perché avremo bisogno
di tutta la nostra intelligenza.
Agitatevi perché avremo bisogno
di tutto il nostro entusiasmo.
Organizzatevi perché avremo bisogno
di tutta la nostra forza.”
Grazie.
(Applausi)